[MUSIC PLAYING]
AMANDA LEICHT MOORE:
So welcome, folks,
to G. University
Counsel's fireside chat
on inclusive products.
I'm Amanda Leicht Moore, and
I'm one of the PM leads on Maps.
And so with that, I'd like
to introduce our moderator,
Brandi [INAUDIBLE], who has been
at Google for about nine years,
works on our executive
summits team.
And I'll hand it over to
Brandi to introduce our panel.
BRANDI: Thank you, guys,
for joining us today.
I also want to introduce
two Googlers who
are joining us via Hangout.
In New York, we have Dan
Pritchett, an engineering
director on the GO team.
If you can wave, Dan.
And we have in the Seattle area
Caleb Davis, a program manager
also on the GO team.
And I want to let
everyone know who
is watching via live stream,
we have a Dory up that should
be presenting shortly.
And Maurice--
MAURICE TURNER: Brandi.
BRANDI: Maurice and I have
been friends for over 20 years.
He has quite an
impressive resume.
He has his Bachelor of
Arts in political science
from Cal State, Fullerton,
a Master of Arts
in public administration from
the University of Southern
California.
And that is in emerging
communication technologies,
privacy, and civic engagement.
And he has a
graduate certificate
in cybersecurity strategy
from Georgetown University.
He's currently a Senate fellow
for the Republican Homeland
Security and Governmental
Affairs Committee
supporting cybersecurity.
It goes without saying that
I've been in awe of Maurice
for the last 20 years.
He's worked across many
government agencies.
And he's managed to navigate
some complex bureaucracies
to raise awareness around
racist and offensive place
names in the United States.
His work is literally
changing the map.
And it's amazing
to me that he is
working to dismantle structural
racism in the United States.
So please join me in welcoming
Maurice Turner to Google.
[APPLAUSE]
MAURICE TURNER: Thank you.
BRANDI: So I'm personally
very interested in hearing
your process that
got you here today.
And I know that there's people
who are here and watching
via live stream that also
would like to understand
the process that you developed
and took to change those place
names, so they could potentially
follow in your footsteps.
But first, I would like
to ask you to take us back
to that day in 2015 when you
and your lovely wife [? Preet ?]
were hiking in
Shenandoah National Park.
What happened?
MAURICE TURNER: Well, excellent.
Thank you.
I appreciate the time that
you all are offering me
so I can share my story.
We'll start a little
bit earlier than 2015.
I grew up in Southern
California and recently moved
to the DC area.
And so I decided that
I needed to get out,
see what's going on in
Virginia, since that
was going to be my new home.
And that started with a hike--
so getting out enjoying nature.
I came from Southern California.
These whole things called
seasons, which kind of
dictate what you
can do and where
you can do it were new to me.
So summertime was around.
This is July 2015.
I would go for a hike,
take some photos,
come back home, load them up
in my computer, and open a map.
And that's where I
see that I just was.
There's a stream there
called Negro Run.
And when I first saw it
come up on Google Maps,
I thought that has to be a typo.
There's no way that
there's actually
a place called Negro Run.
And it kind of sat
with me a little bit.
And as I was
thinking about it, I
was considering, OK, well,
it's obviously not a typo.
There's some history that
I need to learn about.
So over the course of
the following weeks
and a couple of months,
I began to learn
more about the history
of Shenandoah National
Park and its own struggles with
segregation and desegregation
in the '30s and '40s.
And I just had this
feeling in my stomach
that it just-- it
didn't sit well with me,
that that was a name
that was still there.
And so I thought, I
need to change that.
That's something that I
don't want to be around
when I go out to enjoy nature.
So I started that process of
basically just shooting off
emails as far as I
could to whoever I
could think of that might
actually have some powers.
So I sent emails off to the
park superintendent, the region
director, the director of
the national park system,
the Secretary of the Department
of Interior, just anyone
that I could think of
that might actually
have some power to help
make this change come about.
BRANDI: Wow.
So when you were
doing this research,
you used Google Maps to identify
the place that you were at.
And then you named a couple
of different agencies.
In your process of
discovery this place name,
what did you learn about
other offensive place
names in the US?
MAURICE TURNER: Well, I learned
that they're everywhere.
They are literally
racist place names
all over the country
in every state
that we have in our country.
And so it was just
really shocking to me
that we could have names
like this that would reflect
a time in history
that wasn't inclusive,
that didn't respect the
diversity that we now
have in our country.
And thankfully, the
government agency
that's in charge of
recognizing these names
is very well documented.
They've been around since 1890.
And so as you can
see, there are cards--
name cards.
And one of the
things that I learned
was that Negro Run was
actually a compromised name.
That was a name that was
applied in the early '60s.
It used to be called Nigger
Run, which is something that I
had to come to terms with.
It's not a word that I
like to use or a word
that I like to hear.
But I recognize that
our words have power.
And there is a certain
power in using that word,
either toward people
or around people,
because it's meant to hurt.
It's meant to inflict
a level of pain
upon people that
are being referred
to in a derogatory sense.
And that helped push me toward
going through the effort
and following up over
the months, which
ended up being over a year,
to get the name changed.
Interesting little
note of history--
1933, as we saw
on that name card,
the name was actually
changed to Nigger Run.
I believe that there is a
correlation between the timing
of that change being 1933,
because in 1932, the Shenandoah
National Park was actually
supposed to have a concession
facilities built in an area of
the park that was desegregated
and meant to serve
only colored people,
as they referred to at the time.
So in my mind, the only
reason that the name
could have been changed from
its original name, Tims River,
to something that is
so blatantly offensive
is that there were a
dedicated group of people
who lived nearby that felt so
strongly that the named needed
to change that they
actually petitioned
the federal government and
proposed to have this change.
And then that committee, the
Domestic Names Committee,
actually agreed to
change the name.
BRANDI: What was the process
like to actually find
this documentation?
Was it relatively easy to
uncover these documents?
MAURICE TURNER: The
information is there,
but it's not easy to get to.
So obviously, you
need to know that it's
the Department of the
Interior that is then
over the US
Geological Survey that
is in over the Board of
Geographic Names, which
is the home of the
Domestic Names Committee.
So you have to go through
several layers of bureaucracy
to actually find out who is
responsible for the names
and where that
information is kept.
So it took some digging.
It took some research.
Thankfully, we're living in a
time where a lot of information
is available online, if we're
willing to search for it.
So I was able to find it.
And they were very diligent
in their recordkeeping.
And so that's how I was
able to find that name card
and find those board minutes,
where they actually captured
some of their conversations
they had at board meetings
to make some of
these name changes.
BRANDI: Can you tell us a little
bit about this documentation
right here?
MAURICE TURNER: Certainly,
in the early '60s,
then Secretary of the Department
of Interior Udall sent out
a memo saying that, as part of
the rise of the Civil Rights
Movement at the time, it
became clear that there were
certain names and
certain words that
were universally derogatory.
And so he directed
the names committee
to make a system wide
change, so to change
every instance of nigger
to negro, which in his mind
was a more appropriate
name to use,
which here we are
these years later,
that is still as offensive
as I'm sure it was then.
But that was the compromise that
he was able to come up with.
That was the direction
that he gave.
And so there was
a sweeping change.
There is only one other instance
of a sweeping change like this.
And that happened 1974,
where the name Jap
was replaced at a system
level with the name Japanese.
So of all of the
derogatory names
you can come up with
in your mind that
would disparage someone's race,
ethnicity, cultural background,
there's only two
that this committee
view as being derogatory.
There's only those two
words that they will refuse
to approve in a name change.
What I'd say is most frustrating
about this whole process is
that the committee recognizes
that those two words are so
bad, they're not going to
approve any new names using
those words.
But there is no process in
place to go back and change
all of the other--
over 1,000 racist place names
that we have in the country.
BRANDI: And you
said the last time
there was a sweeping
change was in the '70s?
MAURICE TURNER: 1974.
BRANDI: Wow.
Wow.
So maybe this answer is
obvious, but why did you
take on this mission beyond
just changing the place
name that you discovered?
MAURICE TURNER:
As I said earlier,
it literally sat in my stomach.
And it's been sitting there and
bothering me and motivating me
for almost two years
now, that this is just
something that needs to change.
As we've talked about, we've
known each other for 20 years.
And the reason that
we know each other
is very memorable in that
we would go on these field
studies, these field trips
through our high school biology
class.
And it was such a strong,
positive experience
to go out in nature, meet new
people who then become friends,
experience all the variety
that we have in our country
in a natural way.
And I think, what
would have changed
in my life experience had we
been out in Yosemite National
Park and I'd come
across a Negro Run?
How would I have been
able to cope with that?
How would my
teachers, my friends,
my family been able to
explain to me at a young age
why that name exists
and why it exists
in such an official capacity?
BRANDI: I'm guessing there's a
lot of people who are inspired.
They're going to want to
help you with this mission.
And I know that Dan and
Caleb, who are joining us,
were on the receiving end
of a lot of documentation
from you and of your story.
I was hoping that
Dan and Caleb, you
can help us understand
the documentation
that Maurice provided
for you guys to help
you make this change on Maps.
CALEB DAVIS: Sure.
Most of it really boils down to
the offices reports from GNIS.
And those reports are
really what we need in order
to make changes on the map.
We need official government
resources, in most cases,
in order to make changes.
So luckily, Maurice had
done all of this legwork.
We went through an amazing
amount of effort, not only
to change the name, but he
had also tracked down all
of this information.
He forwarded it to Dan.
Dan forwarded it to the
[INAUDIBLE] data escalations
team, which is a
team I'm part of.
We're kind of like the last line
of defense for GO data problems
on Maps.
And we were able to quickly make
change with the internal tools
that we have.
BRANDI: And can you
help us understand
why the change was
made so swiftly--
the documentation that Maurice
provided, either the quantity
or the way that it
was presented to you?
CALEB DAVIS: Well, we
are an escalations team.
And we really do
care about things
that are offensive that have
potential PR implications.
That's really kind of our
purpose, is to do these fixes.
And certainly, this
when it came in
fell very high in
our priority list.
And luckily, the folks
that Dan works with that
maintain the GO pipeline have
built the pipeline in a way
that those changes can propagate
to Google Maps very quickly.
So we just-- our end really
isn't rocket science.
It's really just [INAUDIBLE].
It's doing the hard work of
going in the tools of making
these changes.
And we were able to do that.
We take a lot of these
written reports internally
and basically take
action on them.
Usually, they're not as
gratifying to work on
as a report like this one.
But this is pretty
much what we do.
BRANDI: And, Dan, can
you talk a little bit
about how you
reacted when you saw
Maurice's story on the
black Googler network Alias?
DAN PRITCHETT: Well, sure.
I saw your email.
And this seemed like
such an obvious thing
that we needed to take care of.
And to reinforce what
Caleb said that Maurice
had done the critical work us.
One of the things that--
we try to make the map
factually accurate.
And unfortunately,
sometimes we have
these of situations, where
the facts aren't facts
that we like.
By Maurice having this name
change in place, to me,
it was something
that I saw, it's
like-- well, I saw your email.
And I was like, well,
this is something
that I deal with working
with Caleb and his team
all the time in terms of
dealing with these kinds
of escalations.
So just let me pick this
up and get that over there.
And it clearly was one
that we wanted to treat
with a fair amount of urgency.
BRANDI: And what
are these reports
that are in the deck that
are on display right now?
Can you help us understand
what these represent?
DAN PRITCHETT: Caleb,
you want to take that?
CALEB DAVIS: Sure.
So these are basically
the official citations
from GNIS that more
or less give us
the information about what
is considered basically
the official government name.
And in this particular
case, because Maurice
was able to petition the US
Board on Geographic Names
to have the name changed
back to Tims River,
we were able to
use that resource.
We're basically
allowed to do that.
There are a lot of
implications for us as far as
what resources we can use.
So we really do have to limit
it to a fairly small number
of things, like official
government resources
and resources that
are explicitly
approved by our P counsel.
And this particular report,
it has a very good description
of the location of the
river, when this was defined.
There's a series of
identifications for it.
But that's pretty much all there
is to it for the GNIS report.
BRANDI: So I imagine there
would be a lot of changes
that are happening constantly.
How would we scale
something like this?
DAN PRITCHETT: So
the good news is
that a major priority
for Google, Google
Maps product, and actually
has been through all of 2016
as well, is to allow users to
provide us with information
about the map, to tell us about
things that are wrong that we
have factually incorrect.
So the one thing that
I'm looking forward to
is being able to continue
to get these reports in.
We have both a combination of
algorithms as well as people,
both users and
operators, that can
help us make decisions
on these edits
as to whether we should
accept them or not.
Now, it is a little challenging
for things like rivers.
We don't have river
names that is a feature
that we support just yet.
But our goal is to
continue to open up
more and more of the things
that can be edited on the map,
so that individual users
can actually tell us
about things that are wrong.
BRANDI: And you said that
one of your first things you
did when you came
back from the park
was to go onto Google Maps.
Did you start the process
of reporting this initially
on Maps?
MAURICE TURNER: You know,
I don't think that I did.
I try to be pretty
well-documented.
And I don't have
that in my notes.
I know that it's kind
of come full circle.
And that's been the
most fulfilling part
of this whole process that
I've been involved with,
in that I first saw the
name on Google Maps.
And you go through
an 18-month period
of figuring out who to talk
to, following up, following up,
waiting, being
patient, having to go
through the bureaucratic steps.
And then it truly was that
I was very happy when I saw
the board approved the name.
But I was the most
satisfied when
I saw the update
happen on Google Maps.
It was just that recognition
that in modern day,
it's not the paper map,
it's the digital map.
That's what people see.
There are more
people seeing maps,
because they have smartphones,
they have computers.
They simply have more
access to the information.
And that information
is, quite frankly,
for most people are
going to be digital.
So it may take 5, 10
years for paper maps
in the area to be updated.
It may take another 10 or 20
years for books to be updated.
It might even take
a full generation
before the people who
live in that area change
the name they use colloquially.
But for Google Maps, it
happened in 24 hours.
And the impact of
that has the potential
to reach millions of people.
And so that's probably
the most proud
that I am of this whole process,
is that so many more people
have access to this new name.
And it gives so much more
weight to the power that we all
have to be able to change
names, to change things
that we see as being wrong, and
standing up and saying, hey,
this is absolutely not
right, this is offensive,
this is derogatory.
Maybe not to me
personally, but it's
derogatory to
someone that I know
or someone that I could
know or just in general.
So there is that ability
to change it and have
it reach all those people.
It's just-- it's
pretty incredible.
BRANDI: So what are
you doing to change
place names beyond Google Maps?
MAURICE TURNER: Well, I'm just
here in my personal capacity.
I'm not here representing
where I work or my fellowship.
And in my role
personally, the way
that I see it is
just to show people
that there is a way to
make this change happen.
There are over 1,400
racist place names.
There are places like
Dead Negro Hollow
in Tennessee, Dago Springs,
Chinaman's Hat, Squaw Tit
Summit.
And just there are so many
names that are out there.
So I would just say that
if you come across a name
when you're out walking
around and enjoying nature
and you think that that
name needs to be changed,
there is a process
to go through.
The change can happen.
But the only way the
change can happen
is if someone submits
a proposal and says,
hey, there's something
wrong with this name,
here's a better idea.
Please go ahead and at
least have the discussion
with the local
community to come up
with a better name,
something that's
more reflective of the
community as it is today,
not as it was in the past,
where derogatory names were
more acceptable.
BRANDI: I imagine
there are going
to be a lot of people who
have some passion around this
and would like to help.
What would you suggest
their first steps be?
Or how can they help you?
And what are your next
steps going to be?
MAURICE TURNER: Well,
this was a big next step--
was just coming out
and sharing my story.
So I appreciate you inviting
me to the Google Campus
and for all of you coming
out and all of you,
wherever you are
in your offices,
hearing firsthand
what I went through.
I just ask that you find a
name that you find offensive
and you take the 5 or
10 minutes to learn
a little bit about the name and
propose a better alternative.
So that way, the
process can start.
And I'm hoping that once
that decision is made,
there'll be another
quick turnaround.
So the Google Maps team can
make that change digital
and reach more people.
So if you're interested, feel
free to contact me via email.
There's a very long
spreadsheet that I have.
I'm more than happy to share
with anyone who would like.
But there are plenty
of names out there.
Just next time you're
out walking around,
everything has a name.
And some of those names
aren't appropriate anymore.
And we know the
power of language
and we know how we can hurt.
But we also know
how it can help.
So let's try to come
up with some better
names for these places
that need to be changed.
BRANDI: And you're going to
be running in the Shenandoah
National Park Half Marathon,
right, to raise awareness?
MAURICE TURNER: I am.
So over Labor Day, I'm
going to be out running--
not my favorite thing to do.
But I figure it's a good way
to get out and enjoy the park.
And I want to go see
that new Tims River.
BRANDI: Awesome.
Congratulations.
MAURICE TURNER: Thank you.
BRANDI: So now,
we'd like to open
the session to either live
Q&A or the Dory questions.
Does anybody in the room
have any pressing questions
for Maurice?
How about-- oh.
AUDIENCE: I have.
In the intro that
you gave, I think
you said that one
of Maurice's goals
was to dismantle
structural racism.
BRANDI: That was my
take on what he's doing.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
So I wanted to ask
you more about that,
if that's one of your goals.
Is this just one
piece of that goal?
MAURICE TURNER: It's one piece.
I'm definitely a
process-oriented person.
I have a professional
career in government.
And so I like those
details just to be perfect,
because I know that that's where
a lot of the challenge lies.
There are lots of big problems
that we all need to work on.
And those can sometimes
be intimidating.
So I like to look at
the details and say, OK,
what's something that I
can do as an individual
to have an impact on,
because the racism is
out there everywhere.
And so I believe that
it's up to everyone
to take the opportunity to
find a little piece of it,
wherever they happen to be,
and take that on as a challenge
to get rid of it.
So for me, it was Negro
Run in Shenandoah National
Park in Virginia.
And I think that if I can go
out and get one little creek
or river renamed, that
anyone else can go do it.
And the cumulative
effect of that is you
would then have
over 1,400 pieces
of institutionalized
racism gone.
The challenge-- and I'm sure
that folks in the GO team
understand-- is that
there is this balance
between factual accuracy
and historical records.
So I think it's important
to recognize that there
is history behind these names.
Places change names over
the course of history.
And it's not
necessary that a place
keep its name the entire time.
But there needs to
be a record of it.
And I think, at least
when we're talking
about place names recognized
by the federal government,
there's good
recordkeeping, so I'm not
afraid to go out
and ask for a place
to have a new name that's more
reflective of the community
that exists today.
So that's my contribution to it.
I can't take on all of it
and fix racism in America.
But I took on a
racist name of a river
in a national park in Virginia.
So that way, tomorrow, 10 years
from now, 100 years from now,
no one else has to see that and
have that negative experience.
They can go to
that national park
and have a positive experience.
AUDIENCE: Got it.
Thanks.
BRANDI: Maurice, thank you so
much for coming to Google today
and sharing your story with us.
It was my honor.
MAURICE TURNER: My
pleasure, absolutely.
BRANDI: Thank you.
MAURICE TURNER: Thank you,
Brandi, appreciate it.
BRANDI: Thank you guys.
[APPLAUSE]